I joined the army back in 1995 when I
was 17 years old if you remember in 1995
Oklahoma City experienced a uh terrorist
bombing and it inspired me to do
something to help my
community my name is Marne Robbins
Hoffman I was in the Connecticut Army
National Guard I'm currently assigned as
a patrol Sergeant at the Yale Police
Department having the Yale veterans
community behind us and with us walking
with us
is helpful because it is a group of
people that have been through some of
the same challenges that we've all been
through Veterans Day has a great meaning
to me this is a day for us to remember
everything that we've done everything
that we've achieved and to remember the
friendships and the camaraderie that
we've made throughout our time in the
military most of all it's a day of deep
appreciation for everybody that's ever
worn a
[Music]
uniform